live local now it's a touching story  a fifth grader in arizona and his  friends are coming together this  mother's day to raise money for his mom  colton's mom stacy was recently  diagnosed with stage four colon cancer  it's now spread to her  lungs and liver the 43-year-old mother  is determined to fight through it  using colton and his two sisters as  inspiration  i just wanted to help my mom any way  possible  because it's a really hard time going  through  right now there's another choice i'm a  mom i i have to roar  i have to bring out my inner strength  for them  and i'm doing it and so i just fight i  fight every day  colton and his friends have been selling  lemonade all week so far they've raised  about one thousand dollars there's a  gofundme for the family as well